- [Instructor] Which
expression is equivalent
to the following quotient for all a
is greater than zero, b greater than zero,
and c greater than zero?
Now one of the reasons why they had
to restrict a, b, and c is
because if they actually equaled
zero, you would be dividing by zero there,
which would be an issue.
And actually, this whole expression,
if a or b were zero, this whole thing
would be zero, then once again,
you'd be dividing by zero,
which would be an issue.
So, by constraining it,
they're avoiding that problem.
But let's see if we can simplify it.
So we got all of this and we just have
to remember, dividing by a fraction
is equivalent to multiplying
by its reciprocal.
Reciprocal, so this is
going to be the same thing
as this top, actually
let me color-code it,
as this top expression.
So, 3a to the third, b to the fifth,
over c to the third, times so let
me actually stay in that color.
So that thing times the reciprocal
of this business right over here.
So times the reciprocal, so
25, c to the fourth power
over 15ab squared.
And so, what's this going to be?
Well, let's see, in the numerator,
in the numerator, you're going
to have three times 25 is 75.
And then a to the third, b to the fifth,
c to the fourth, c to the fourth.
And then in the denominator,
so you're gonna have 15
times a, times b squared,
times c to the third power.
Now we can try to simplify.
So what's 75 divided by 15?
Or if you divide 75 by
15, you're gonna get five.
And if you divide, if you
divide 15 by 15, you get one.
So the coefficient on this
thing's just gonna be five.
So immediately if I was
under time pressure,
I would just stop there and say hey look,
the only one of these
choices that has only
a five out front is this
choice right over here,
so I'm feeling pretty good about it.
But I could continue to simplify.
a to the third divided, if I divide
a to the third by a, a to the third and a,
I could divide these both by
a, this becomes a squared,
this becomes one.
b to the fifth divided by b squared,
well that's gonna be b to the third power.
So, this is going to be
b to the third power.
This is going to be one.
c to the fourth divided by c to the third,
this is going to be c.
c to the third divided by c to the third
is just going to be equal to one.
So you've got five a
squared b to the third,
c which is exactly what you have here.
If what I did right at the end here
looks a little bit
unfamiliar, I encourage you
to review exponent
properties on Khan Academy,
that should help out, but
I'll do a little primer here.
If I just, let me just do it simplified.
If I had 75a squared over 15a,
yeah I hope, I guess you
get the 75 over 15 part,
that's going to be equal to five.
So let me, I could
rewrite this as 75 over 15
times a squared over a.
This is five, and one way to view this
is, this is a squared over a to the first,
our exponent properties tell us that this
is going to be the same thing
as a to the two minus one power,
which is equal to a to the first power.
And this is the same thing as saying,
well let's just divide both the numerator
and the denominator by
a, and you're just going
to be left with a.
So this part over here,
this would just be 5a.
This is obviously a
simplified version just
to feel good about the
exponent properties.
Similarly, b to the fifth
divided by b squared,
that's gonna be b to the
five minus two power,
which is b to the third.
c to the fourth minus c to the third,
well that's gonna be c to
the four minus three power,
which is c to the first power,
which is this choice right here.